Now, here's something nobody tells you
about being everyone's favorite person.
It's absolutely exhausting. We've turned
people pleasing into a sophisticated art
form. We'll spend 20 minutes crafting
the perfect text message to avoid any
possible misunderstanding. But we can't
spend 2 minutes asking ourselves what we
actually want for lunch. Here's the
uncomfortable truth that's going to
challenge everything you think you know
about being a good person. People
pleasing doesn't actually please people.
Think about the people you respect most
in your life. Are they the ones
constantly agreeing with you, never
rocking the boat? Or are they the ones
who challenge you, speak their truth,
and show up authentically even when it's
uncomfortable? Wait, what if I told you
that the most selfless people in the
world are those who admit to living for
themselves? When you fill your own cup
first, you have something real to pour
out. Your authenticity is your gift to
the world.